مشاهدينا نتابع معكم الان هذه الصور
المباشره لوصول طائره الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون الى مطار بكين الدولي حيث
يبدا الرئيس الفرنسي زياره تدوم لثلاثه
ايام وذلك في محمد وساطه في ملف الحرب
الاوكرانيه
كان اعلن في بيان ان الرئيس الفرنسي
جو بايدن تحدثا في اتصال هاتفي عن رغبتهما
المشتركه في اشراك الصين في تسريع انهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا والمشاركه كذلك في بناء
سلام دائم في المنطقه الخارجي الفرنسيه
ايضا مشاهدينا اعلنت من جهتها ان الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون سيبلغ القاده الصينيين
خلال زيارته بضروره الامتناع عن دعم الجهد
الروسي في النزاع الاوكراني اذا زلنا معكم
مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه الصور المباشره
لوصول طائره الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون الى بكين في زياره رسميه تستمر
بثلاثه ايام